a bunch of Assassin's Creed victory
details have leaked ahead of its
upcoming revealed this week those
include the fact that it's now called
Assassin's Creed syndicate that's
confusing but stick with me according to
polygon who got their hands on some
marketing material syndicate will
revolve around an assassin called Jake
fry and the game will be set in a
recreation of London during the
industrial revolution as we suspected
movies up to themselves haven't revealed
anything about the game officially save
for a picture of some brass knuckles and
a teaser animation featuring a gauntlet
with a hidden blade and the sweet cane
probably also concealing some kind of
weapon at present the loot details are
not official although Ubisoft didn't out
that they plan to unveil the newest
Assassin's Creed titles this Tuesday
it's suspected that Assassin's Creed
syndicate will make its way to ps4 xbox
one and pc let me know if you're keen
for an assassin's creed game set in
london during the industrial revolution
or if there's a setting you prefer we'll
keep you updated on everything
Assassin's Creed as it happens on
gamespot